SIMON PAMPENA: The point about
points is that our idea of
points, like when we go
like this, we go,
here's my point, 3.5.
I'm going to move
it over here.
Here's 3.5, right?
That's wrong.
That's not 3.5.
If that was really 3.5,
we wouldn't be
able to see a thing.
A point is not a small
tiny circle.
That's just a representation.
And what it does is it gives
us the wrong sense of how
things are.
Like if you remove a point,
OK, and if it was, in your
mind, of a ruler, you should be
able to hold it up to the
sun and see a little bit of
sunlight shine through.
But that's wrong.
It's impossible.
Because if that was the case,
we'd be removing a little bit
of length, and then we
wouldn't have one.
So this is pushing our notions
of what maths is, which
is why I love it.
I love this stuff.
BRADY HARAN: But your whole
premise, your discussion here
is how do we measure numbers.
SIMON PAMPENA: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Who wants
to measure numbers?
Who said numbers were measurable
in the first place?
Why is this a problem for you?
SIMON PAMPENA: Why is
this a problem?
BRADY HARAN: You don't
measure numbers.
Numbers are--
SIMON PAMPENA: Why this
is a problem?
BRADY HARAN: Numbers are what
you do the measuring with.
SIMON PAMPENA: Why is
this a problem?
Because we are using stuff
that we haven't proved.
We're using naive notions
of measure.
That's why that's a problem.
We're making assumptions.
This almost broke maths, where
I'm going with this.
It almost broke maths.
And that sounds like I'm being
really full-on, but it's
absolutely true.
And I know I'm going to be able
to show you the exact
reason why it almost
broke maths.
But what I'm talking about here,
I can tell you right now
what this led to.
This led to the computer,
what I'm talking about.
The hair's standing up in the
back of my neck when I talk
about this.
That's how exciting this is.
It's so exciting that people
started going, oh, I know how
to measure.
You take one.
You take the final.
You take the initial.
Sure.
That's all right.
Well, what happens when
you remove points?
What happens when you remove an
infinite number of points?
Let's just think about
it like this.
Let's go from 0 to 12.
So the length of that is 12.
So 12 take 0 is 12.
That's the length.
So then I'm going to wrap
it around a clock face.
Whoops.
That's not a very good clock.
It's more like an egg.
So there's 12 there, 9, OK?
And the reason why I'm going
to show you this is because
now I'm going to mark
out every fraction.
So it's almost like every single
way that you could
divide up time in a way that
would be sensible.
I'm actually going to put holes,
tiny little holes all
around the clock face.
Now, this is where I'm hopefully
going to break your
brain, because now I've removed
every single fraction
on the segment of
the number line.
And the fact that I've made
it 12 doesn't matter.
What's the length of
this line now?
Remember, the real number line
contains numbers other than
fractions because most of
the real number line are
transcendental numbers.
What's kind of crazy is that in
this case, though, between
any two fractions, so between
any two fractions, so let's
just say here between 0 and 1,
you have removed 1/2, yeah?
But you've also removed 1/4, and
1/8, and 1/16, and a 32th.
Rah, rah, rah.
It keeps going do, do, do, do,
do, do, all the way down.
So between any two fractions
is another fraction, and
between any two fractions
is another fraction.
So in maths, they
call it dense.
It's dense with numbers.
So it should make you feel a
little bit uneasy that you
might be making a mistake.
What we can play with is how
many points there are.
So what you can do is you can
count out all the numbers.
This is a fraction here.
So you could go-- it's this
on this, whatever it is.
So that's 2 on 1.
This is 2 on 2.
This is 2 on 3.
This is 2 on 4, et cetera,
et cetera.
So each point represents
a fraction.
And you've kind of covered every
single possible fraction
that there is, right?
And what we're trying to do is
we're trying to show that
this, all the fractions, are
countable or listable.
So this is the really
great thing.
And what you do is you
draw this snake.
So you draw the snake like so.
And you draw it like that.
And you're basically going,
I can create a
list of all the fractions.
If we know that we can list all
these points, let's make a
list of them.
So let's talk about
all the fractions.
Let's call it F, all the
fractions between 0 and 12.
So 1/2 will be in there.
2/3 will be in there.
4/3 will be in there,
whatever.
If that's listable,
let's measure the
length of all of them.
So the length, what's
the length of 1/2?
Well, that's 0.
What's the length of 2/3?
What's the length of 4/3?
Well, that's 0.
Boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo.
So I've got an infinite
sum of 0.
So 0 added to itself infinitely
many times?
0.
So it's because of the number,
in a sense, the number, even
though it's infinite, and
infinite really isn't a
number, but the fact that the
type of infinite it is--
a countable infinite,
and it's listable--
means that if we remove a
countable number of points, a
listable number of points, we
haven't changed the length
because the length of all those
points have to be 0.
BRADY HARAN: If I remove
your feelings--
SIMON PAMPENA: Yeah?
BRADY HARAN: --your
size won't change.
Just like if I remove the
numbers, the infinitely small,
abstract numbers from a line,
the length of the
line doesn't change.
Numbers don't have volume or
size, because they're just an
abstract thing.
They're a describing word.
Are we starting to come towards
philosophy here?
SIMON PAMPENA: No.
I'm just a bit weirded out by
you removing my feelings.
Without my feelings,
I can't do maths.
Because it's all
very emotional.
See, this is the thing, is that
you're putting a nice
analogy on something when this
is already an analogy.
The problem is that humans--
and mathematicians--
we are really analogizing.
Even the maths that you see, in
a sense, it's an analogy.
Just like how Roman numbers
was like-- they
thought they had it.
They thought, yeah.
We know numbers.
They're never going to change.
We're in charge.
And they've changed.
And it's because there's
been a better way
to represent numbers.
And I think what I love about
this is that we draw a line.
Well, first of all, you
can't draw a line.
It's impossible.
It's just a very, very
thin rectangle.
And you draw points.
That's ridiculous.
You can't draw points.
But there you go.
We draw points.
And then suddenly, we go, oh,
I know what to do there.
Because I know how
to use a ruler.
You do final, take initial,
fantastic.
Suddenly something make
sense in maths.
[BUZZER NOISE]
It doesn't make sense.
Suddenly, you're confronted with
these conundrums of like,
what happens when I
take away a point?
Well, nothing, because there is
no next point, like there
is no hole per se.
And so, when you try thinking
about it, you actually have to
start questioning every
single assumption.
And this is where
this led into an
analysis of set theory.
What assumptions were
mathematicians
making about maths?
Very heavy questions.
What mathematicians
were able to do--
should I go here?
OK, I'll go there.
What mathematicians were able
to do, were able to create
sets of numbers that you
couldn't measure.
And it was linked to these
kinds of ideas.
So you're actually picking all--
the guy who did it was a
guy called Giuseppe Vitali.
And he came up with this idea of
consider the solid segment
between 0 and 1 and consider
all the fractions.
Then he considered every single
copy of that in 0 to 1.
And what that means is it's
very complicated.
It's called a partition.
But basically, he found all
these different copies of it.
Then he just took one point
from every single copy.
And that set you could
not measure.
There was no way you could
get a sensible answer.
Getting 0 is a sensible
answer.
This gave no sensible answer.
It gave a contradiction.
You look at it one way,
you get one answer.
You look at it the other way,
you get a different answer.
That's a problem.
Because I thought I knew
how to measure.
I thought I knew how
to use a ruler.
I thought I knew maths.
And this guy realized that there
were these sets that you
couldn't measure, and that
caused massive problems.
Mathematicians were
very, very upset.
The thing that I realized when I
studied this is that it made
me question what I knew
about numbers.
So my life I see as a timeline
of discovery of numbers.
Why not?
I discovered numbers the way,
watching "Sesame Street" or
whatever you do, and you get a
sense of, oh, yeah, one, two
fractions, you start getting
your head around these things.
But suddenly, when you come to
the point where you think
about how numbers are related
and points and decimal
expansions, all that sort
of stuff, you start
going, wow, 3 is weird.
I thought I knew 3, but
3 is very strange.
The abstraction of these numbers
are very strange.
And what it really drove me to
is to question everything.
You have to question everything
in maths.
There's so much that we bring
in from the outside world,
which just gives you
the wrong idea.
We thought we knew
measure because
measurement was about numbers.
So a ruler, you could
go, there's a ruler.
There a real ruler.
There's a mathematical ruler.
It looks like a ruler.
Surely I can't go
wrong with this.
But what you can do, the sorts
of sets that you can make, the
removal of points, you're really
doing things there's no
way you could do in reality,
no way at all
you could do in reality.
So this is the stuff.
And then exploring
these things,
that's what really gets--
I mean, people actually started
to question reasoning
out of this, how we reason.
And it actually did lead
to the computer.
It actually led--
Alan Turing was the guy who was
trying to reformulate some
of the questions that
came out of this.
He started reformulating
Kurt Godel's work.
And out of that came the Turing
machine, which is, for
all intents and purposes,
the first computer.
It might not be exactly.
But anyway, he's the guy
who came up with it.
And now we're just
trying to think.
Now we're trying to go,
how do you think?
What are the assumptions
we make?
So yeah, so for me, this was
the crowning glory of my
mathematical education, was
really getting to the bottom
of like if I was a musician,
it was like, what is music?
What is it?
Why does it make you
feel a certain way?
BRADY HARAN: But it sounds like
your conclusion is, we
don't know.
SIMON PAMPENA: What
don't we know?
BRADY HARAN: What numbers are.
SIMON PAMPENA: I would love that
because I I'm assuming
it's going to be completely
incomprehensible to me.